[Music]
bangalore feels young and youthful and
you know eager to experiment
bangalore is actually called the silicon
valley of india about 42 percent of
india's startups are born here every
year
it has become this thriving magnet for
talent
india's startup scene is booming
this year alone the country has seen
over three dozen unicorns private
companies valued over one billion
dollars
and much of this impressive growth has
happened in record time
the last decade and a half it's a sea
change we live in such a different world
um today
i think in 2006 if you said we would
have 10 unicorns
let alone close to touching maybe 100
unicorns
that would have uh looked madness
from last september to this september
the on on an average three unicorns
every month so it's a clear indication
of
ecosystem maturing
india has had a record year of ipos
but with a recent stock launch faltering
and fierce global competition can indian
startups keep up this breakneck growth
unlike in the old days when we had to
build everything from scratch today a
lot of the infrastructure for creating a
company exists the challenges will be
how to succeed in the business before
somebody else does better so speed and
execution is becoming even more vital
[Music]
so india's technology story goes back at
least five or six decades
when the government decided it needed a
strategic location to start a whole lot
of defense related technology companies
that would serve governments armed
forces
since then bangalore
became the location for a lot of those
companies and to support them a lot of
educational institutions have come up in
and around bangalore
the government chose bangalore as the
place to build its defence industry as
the southern indian city was considered
a safe distance from its rival countries
pakistan and china in the early 80s
smaller private companies also began to
shift their operations to the city among
them emphasis
in 1981 with initial capital of 250
seven engineers set up the business
marking the beginning of the private
tech industry in india
today it's one of the biggest companies
in the world with a market
capitalization of over 95 billion
dollars
infosys in some sense is india's
original startup when infosys
began in 1981 it was in a socialistic
era when india was not really that
friendly towards business and we had
many many challenges for example just
getting a telephone connection would
take two years
to import even a single computer you
have to go to delhi to get a license
and even if you had to make a small
change
in the configuration of the computer
that you purchased you have to go back
and get the license changed all over
again
then came economic liberalization in the
1990s
the government deregulated markets and
reduced taxes and import tariffs
emphasis and other it companies thrived
in 1993 emphasis went public and built
india's first software campus in
bangalore
prompted by this technology boom in the
1990s people from all over india poured
into bangalore to work or study
so bangalore was the takeoff point for a
lot of those people that came to study
and then went overseas to study further
to get postgraduate degrees or work in a
lot of these global companies perhaps
most of them in the united states and
they've made a comfortable life for
themselves overseas and never returned
but something changed in the late 1990s
and 2000s bangalore became a valid
destination to chase a career in
technology on its own
many local talents especially those from
humble roots decided to stay
lots of overseas indians returned to
bangalore as well vani cola was one of
them she built and sold two startups in
silicon valley before starting a venture
capital firm in bangalore in 2006.
i was in india end of 2005
for a long trip which i hadn't done
in the two decades that i was gone and
for me it was just a very different
country to the one i left there was so
much confidence so much potential so
much opportunity
i saw a big future for startup india
what i saw was the underserved consumer
experience
india consumer story just ready to
embrace
many many new business models and
entrepreneurship that could successfully
build very high scale companies
but the startup culture itself i could
trace back to
about 2007
when flipkart was born so flipkart is
one of india's two large online
retailers two engineers who used to work
for amazon decided that why don't we
start an online retailer like amazon by
ourselves so the two of them got
together in a little apartment not far
from where i'm standing in koramangala
in bangalore and they decided to start
flipkart
like amazon flipkart started out selling
just books and slowly expanded into
other areas including fashion by
acquiring e-commerce startup mntra in
2014.
kohler was an early investor in myntra
flipkart acquiring myntra was a really
smart move
flipkart had already dominated many
categories except fashion at that time
and mintra was the faction leader so it
made sense that combined they would have
a only real horizontal platform that
truly came out of india
and today flipkart is one of the biggest
startups in india the company was bought
by walmart for 16 billion dollars in
2018. making the two founders
billionaires the story of indian
e-commerce started out as uh as
definitely not something that we see
today
uh i don't think anybody expected what
really happened in the last seven eight
years it's been it's been a tremendous
journey
there used to be a time when a startup
in entrepreneurs in india was shunned
entrepreneurs or people who worked in
startups told me that in india's
arranged marriage system parents were
not willing to have their daughters
married to startup entrepreneurs or
workers in startups
that whole thing has changed because of
people like you know sachin bunsel bini
bunsel the two
entrepreneurs who set up flipkart and
sold it all of those stories have now
made being a startup entrepreneur or
working in a startup a very valid career
option for a lot of young indians
the turning point for a lot of the
technology startups and particularly the
internet startups in india has been the
arrival of reliance's jio telecom
service four five years ago when
reliance launched the service
india had very expensive broadband
internet now mukesh ambani one of the
world's richest men decided that he
wanted to offer
calling for free and data broadband
internet services at dirt cheap prices
smartphones are becoming cheaper a lot
of chinese brands were introducing
really sleek inexpensive devices so
multiple types of internet startups
started getting launched in india and
particularly in bangalore startup
ecosystem started catching fire
a part of that early ecosystem was
online education firm by jews today it's
become india's most valuable startup
with seven million paying users
unlike the first generation of indian
tech companies who solve problems for
global companies the current generation
of startups like baidu's are trying to
solve local issues
initial years
when we were offline scaling that model
was a big challenge we started this to
solve three big challenges which exist
in our education system one challenge
around access to good teachers
learning driven by fear of exams
unfortunately and not love for learning
and more importantly it's impossible to
personalize the way you deliver classes
when there are
30 35 40 students sitting in a classroom
now to solve these challenges at scale
it's very important to use technology as
an enabler
at the right time when smartphones were
taking off apps were taking off we were
able to
launch our first learning app that's in
2015
august
and with time with more people coming
online with the data becoming better and
cheaper we've been able to scale our
model around so using smartphones as a
medium to reach out
[Music]
2021 has been a breakout year for these
startups during the covert 19 pandemic
many consumers have turned to online
services for grocery deliveries tutoring
and medical diagnosis contributing to
surging revenues billions of dollars
have poured into india in july for
instance as in china the communist party
has cracked down on a lot of these
technology companies indian startups
gathered almost 8 billion dollars in
venture and pe capital making india for
the very first time overtake china as a
venture capital destination
record numbers of unicorns have been
born at an unprecedented speed
and investors are hoping to profit from
companies that could become the next
google or facebook global investors
always asked
where is the exit and in startup lingo
that means
how do i
make a return on my investment suddenly
a lot of these startups have plans to
debut in the public markets and now that
is a legit exit and investors then
triple four times 10 times their
investments
that is what's happened this year with
the public market debut of a food
delivery startup called zamato which was
really the game changer i think thrice
at our in our journey we've gotten to a
point that
we can't do this anymore right and this
just cannot be done
but um
we actually like continue for one more
day and it's and it all gets over and it
all starts again
zomato as a company is neither
profitable and its medium term prospects
for profitability are really mediocre
but retail investors have lapped up the
shares of zamato sending the valuation
of the company soaring to 13 billion on
debut
but digital payment firm paytm's ipo in
november which is india's biggest ever
has been a disappointment
it raised 2.5 billion dollars but the
stock price has sunk dramatically making
it one of the worst initial showings by
a major tech firm since the dot-com
bubble era of the late 1990s
like zamato paytm is not profitable and
its ipo debacle casts a shadow over
other indian startups the indian startup
world has to show that they are not only
building growth but also
profitability when you look at the
founders of the first generation of
companies in india like infosys or web
pro and so on
they were as i said they had to be
financially very prudent they had to
generate profits from their business and
and feed that back into the business
because that was the only source of
capital that we could reinvest today's
entrepreneurs
are encouraged by their backers to grow
quickly even if they don't have to make
a profit the thesis is that once you
grow and reach a certain critical size
in the market segment of your choice
then you can always make your company
profitable
profitability still
weighs off for a lot of the startups of
course there is a 1.3 billion market
that
on the face of it seems like a humongous
market but then there is the other side
to it that is not enough people with
spending power it all depends on how
many consumers can afford to buy how
much of a middle class india can grow
each year
and who can you know afford to buy these
services
india's 40 000 startups also face other
challenges to grow bigger
compared with china or the us india's
internet industry is still much smaller
in size
and the bureaucracy faced by india's
first generation of private companies
still exists in some ways today pushing
some startups out of the country
sometimes i hear frustration echo
through entrepreneurs voices when they
talk about you know things that are
needed to say apply for an ipo or you
know get a permission to set up an
entity
how complicated the rules are
corporate taxes are very high compared
to countries like singapore and a lot of
the entrepreneurs have then chosen to
shift their bases to countries like
singapore because they find that the tax
regime in singapore
or elsewhere is much friendlier
while it is easy enough to start a
company in india as you scale i think
you run into a lot of areas where
regulation is not clear one thing would
be industry by industry for
government and government bodies to
continue to work to be a step ahead in
terms of providing clear regulatory
guidelines and continuing to engage
industry in modifying that
but starting up in india still has
advantages
half of the indian population is under
the age of 25.
young indians adapt to technology easily
and could be potential consumers with
spending power in the long term they
also provide the country with a rich
talent pool
india has about
four and a half million software
engineers and within the next 10 years
this is going to double
so as the technology talent improves in
the country it will provide a fertile
ground to create more startups it's a
still a nascent ecosystem just about at
takeoff point but a lot of entrepreneurs
are actually dreaming big
entrepreneurship is uh it's it's not a
skill it's a mindset it's a mindset
where you don't take no for an answer
if you are passionate about what you are
doing and if that is making an impact
like i'm sure that we can do this for
decades
you